alors moi quand j'étais dans le
massachusetts alors oui alors les
mannequins j'ai vécu on a tous été
mannequin s'était mal car on le dit pas
mais moi sont le titre a déjà un petit
j'avais un petit appartement en beauté
son dos à tokyo où ça tuerait la selle
c'est un truc de fou quand même une cinq
cas rien à ce qui est en train de semer
la 900 rigolait elle est à new york de
deux minutes la halle à tokyo dans cinq
minutes elle va y trouver tout cet
automne
j'avais fait comment deux pays à bas
tous des filles est content sauf la
laponie je suis jamais allé à bahreïn
est allé on verrait les voilà une qui
trouver l'amour là bas haha ça fait
rêver en tout cas vous verriez quoi vous
allez voir le mec t'as parts à tokyo et
tout d'un coup je me réveille en plein
milieu de la nuit à 3 heures du matin et
je me sens pas bien je tombe non oui
va-t-on gré de faire tant dans le gard
c'est un tremblement l'avait un
tremblement cassé la main ya toujours
des tremblements de terre en pleine
ville la nuit et deux on se sent un peu
et brieuc et brio à bien voilà hybride
hommes du coup on attendait on se sent
et brio
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
d'ici là je crois que ça l'est des tubes
elle pas de sa batmobile d'axa aph h et
demain comme ça cette émission et brio
mascella ah oui c'est ébriété
mais un conducteur conduit en état
d'ivresse voilà une vraie ce lait bio et
brio pour laisser sakho n'est là fait
chaud les sétois connaissez brio tient
sur trois excellents fromages toi d'y
aller c'est brasilia des secousses
sismiques vous tombez vous avez vraiment
l'impression d'être sous bien sûr donc
moi j'ai eu peur donc je suis sorti de
chez moi je suis allé voir mon voisin a
donc du coup bah on a fait des secousses
sismiques ensemble quoi
[Rires]
[Musique]
j'adore